vamos a hablar ahora de economía con
jorge hurtado esta noche en francés 24
jorge buenas noches para usted para
noches angela el canal del suez anunció
un aumento de tarifas para petroleros y
para graneleros así este aumento se debe
un momento en el que el precio
internacional del petróleo se encuentra
al alza en los mercados internacionales
a causa de la invasión en ucrania y de
las posibles sanciones internacionales
contra rusia según la página oficial de
la autoridad del canal de suez que es la
entidad estatal egipcia que gestiona
este paso marítimo desde el primero de
mayo las tarifas adicionales impuestas a
los petroleros con crudo cargado serán
del 15 por ciento de las tarifas de
tránsito normales este es el tercer
anuncio de subidas en un mes para el
transporte de combustibles estas alzas
afectan a los buques que transportan
granos a ellos se les subirá la tarifa
al 10 por ciento esto incide
directamente en el trigo grano cuya
cotización internacional se está
disparando en los mercados
internacionales debido al conflicto
entre rusia y ucrania el canal también
subió el precio del transporte para los
cargueros con derivados del petróleo con
gas el petróleo licuado
vehículos y los que llevan un
portacontenedores según la autoridad del
canal estas tarifas son temporales y se
debe a la mejora en la economía de todos
los buques cargueros o del transporte
marítimo como tal bueno y entretanto el
salvador anunció medidas para
contrarrestar el alza en los precios del
combustible así es este país
centroamericano anunció la suspensión
del cobro del iva a los combustibles
durante 15 días el impuesto grava con un
13 por ciento el consumo final y fue
suspendido por la asamblea de ese país
con el fin de enfrentar la inflación que
afecta a los salvadoreños los precios
actuales de los combustibles en el país
centroamericano rondan los 4,90 dólares
y 470 dólares por galón recientemente
ese país se aprobó una ley especial
transitoria para el combate de la
inflación de precios de productos
básicos que exoneraría de impuestos la
importación de los alimentos según el
banco central de ese país la tasa
interanual de inflación se situó en
febrero en
6,7 por ciento
en cuba se comienza a sentir la falta de
turistas rusos jorge y es que la guerra
en ucrania está frenando el turismo en
la isla tras dos años de pandemia y la
ausencia de turistas americanos por las
sanciones impuestas por donald trump el
turismo cubano se enfrenta ahora a la
falta de turistas rusos la unión europea
canadá y eeuu cerraron el espacio aéreo
a los vuelos comerciales rusos entre
otras sanciones económicas como castigo
por la invasión en ucrania varias
compañías dejaron de vender tiquetes a
la isla hasta finales de marzo en lo que
va de este año cuba recibió casi 400.000
visitantes con los turistas rusos a la
cabeza de estas cifras la asociación
rusa de operadores turísticos dijo por
ejemplo en un comunicado que entre 6.000
y 8.000 turistas rusos estaban en cuba
cuando comenzó la guerra la isla
mantiene su objetivo de 2,5 millones de
visitantes para este año y escuchemos
pues parte de las reacciones allá en
cuba
todo está muy bonito usted puede ver
pero el poco turismo que teníamos cuando
nos estábamos recuperando
el turismo ruso no puede porque llegó la
guerra ucrania saben volvemos en
decadencia y en otros temas en alemania
se inauguró la primera planta de tesla
en europa en el acto se entregaron los
primeros los primeros 30 vehículos
fabricados en esta planta alemana el
canciller de alemania o las sof y su
ministro de economía participaron en la
inauguración de la primera fábrica de
tesla en europa los primeros vehículos
fueron entregados por elon musk el
consejero delegado al fabricante
estadounidense de vehículos eléctricos
las autoridades de alemania dijeron que
la apuesta de tecla es prueba de que el
país es percibido como el mercado líder
para los vehículos eléctricos se espera
que una vez la fábrica entre en total
capacidad genere unos 12.000 puestos de
trabajo y coloque en el mercado al menos
medio millón de vehículos eléctricos muy
bien jorge y quisiera pedirle ahora por
favor los indicadores de las normas
arrancamos en eeuu ahí el índice nasdaq
de tecnología lideró la subida de los
principales índices de wall street con
un alza de casi el 2 por ciento ya que
los inversores compraron
de los valores de empresas como apple
microsoft o amazon.com en europa el dax
40 de fráncfort cerró con una subida del
10 2% pese que la reserva federal de
eeuu se mostró decidida a subir los
tipos de interés y en américa latina la
bolsa de sao paulo alcanzó su mayor
nivel en 2022 impulsado por la banca
privada pues bien así llegamos al final
de este reporte a ustedes gracias a
nuestros televidentes quédense con
nosotros allá volvemos
[Música]